thousands of people have already been
evacuated and people still living in
nearby areas have been told to stay
indoors and away from those fumes this
is the live pictures we've got right now
from the volcano as it continues to
erupt
dramatic stuff well our correspondent
becky cartrio reports now from la palma
it was the moment they've been nervously
waiting for
would the lava make it to the sea
it did
cascading over a cliff edge into the
atlantic ocean
and it kept coming these molten streams
still vicious even after they've left
the land
the steam and gas is created by a
thermal shock when the lava which is
over a thousand degrees celsius hits the
sea which is just over 20 degrees
celsius it releases hydrochloric acid
which is dangerous if you breathe it in
or if it gets in your eyes we are at a
safe distance here but the people in the
towns need ashore have been told to stay
inside
that includes this area
but they're carrying on as normal the
new normal like most they're used to
wearing masks by now
they aren't overly worried here the
direction of the wind means the gas from
the sea has stayed away
this time
[Music]
but there are other fears like the fate
of the fish
people from here the our economy depends
on the
fish industry
so it's really important you know
to
to analyze the future
effects
of this
situation
but scientists say despite the carnage
caused by the eruption on land it will
increase biodiversity on the seabed
we are going to have now an underwater
forest
i mean in a couple of months once
they'll have a cool down
and
of uh in an area that was uh before the
lava
was uh completely
uh
uh
a desert no no no no life at all
the palmer's nickname is la isla bonita
beautiful island right now it's
remarkable look at that headland that's
lava growing and cooling
this place has been changed by this
volcano not just physically and it's
still erupting promising more
destruction becky cultural sky news la
palma